well Saudi Arabia's top leaders are
doubling down on denials of any
involvement in the killing of Washington
Post columnist Jamal Khashoggi our Holly
Williams sat down yesterday with Saudi
foreign minister Adel al-jubeir he
called Ashoka's death a terrible mistake
in a rogue operation Holly Williams is
in Riyadh Saudi Arabia good morning
Saudi Arabia has kept on changing its
story ever since Jamal Hachioji was
killed inside the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul Turkey last month but the Saudi
foreign minister and his government are
adamant that Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman was not involved despite
widespread suspicion that he is culpable
well we've always said that the Saudi
government is not involved in this this
was a rogue operation these individuals
were officials of the government who
exceeded their authority and committed a
crime I mean that's a pretty
extraordinary breach of authority
murdering somebody inside a Saudi
consulate absolutely yes but
unfortunately these things mistakes like
this happen with other governments
according to the Saudi government's most
recent version of events this so-called
mistake was made by a team set to
Istanbul to bring her shocked G back to
Saudi Arabia by force if necessary but
instead a team leader decided to kill
him with a lethal injection president
Trump admitted this week it was possible
the crown prince had knowledge of the
killing but by taking no further action
against Saudi Arabia he was putting
America first in a dangerous world when
US officials have told journalists that
the CIA assessment is that the crown
prince gave the order to kill Jamal
hisagi one of the officials who was
fired and then sanctioned by the US was
an advisor to the Crown Prince
and the former deputy head of
intelligence who apparently sent the
team to Istanbul and was then fired was
also apparently close to the crown
prince isn't that quite damning for the
crown prince
look it's this this is a huge tragedy
the CIA report that you talked about I
haven't seen it so I can't assess it and
what we've heard is the president say
that the CIA report is not what people
say it is
some members of Congress are still
pushing for much tougher action against
Saudi Arabia including Republicans like
Senator Lindsey Graham who's called the
crown prince quote beyond toxic Alex
Holly Williams in Saudi Arabia thanks
Holly